willén sie kann es schaffen meine damen
und herren sie kann es schaffen sie muss
einfach nur geradeaus fahren das ist
[Musik]
ich habe so einen kanal decknamen
senioren zocken und dieser kanal hat
satte 42 1601 abonnenten
da hab ich mir natürlich erst mal
gefragt warum wir sind die senioren die
keine angst haben von neuer technik wir
spielen mit euch und für euch die
neuesten und besten computerspiele
senioren haben wir darin erfahrung nein
beste grüße das seniorenforum team und
ich habe halt in einem video auch gta
gespielt gta 5 let's play mit evelin
senioren zocken deutschlands älteste
let's play rinn und das ist sie das ist
die liebe willen und ich habe mir jetzt
einfach mal so gedacht okay da sitzt sie
erwischt und spielt gta ich würde sagen
wir schauen uns das einfach mal zusammen
an übrigens ist der kanal von denen der
beschreibung verlinkt also schaut er auf
jeden fall mal vorbei die machen ultra
witzige videos liebe leute ihr wollt
gern von uns ein let's play haben
ach ja die haben sogar ein intro was es
geht ja richtig steil bei denen hier
dieses space aus der erste voll geht ja
50 wir mit den senioren im januar
aufgenommen haben gott rechtschreibung
ist noch nicht so ganz da lasst uns
wissen ob wir so etwas öfter sehen wollt
viel spaß beim schauen das heißt
beschaulich das ist einfach mal weiter
an und lassen die fln jetzt mal gta
spielen meine damen und herren es ist
aber süß eigentlich so der evelyn wird
gerade so alles erklärt was da so
stattfindet sie versteht jetzt gerade
wie sie sich bewegen kann und läuft
jetzt mit ihm also ich meine dafür dass
sie wirklich ist ja nicht böse gemeint
aber sie ist ja schon ein bisschen älter
wenn ich meiner oma einen controller in
die hand geben würde mir nur einfach
sagen würde ja bewegt man den joystick
dort die wissen nicht mehr was ein
joystick ist sie
schaut sich jetzt hier in dem gebäude
ein bisschen um das heißt wir schauen
wir mal dabei zu sie läuft sogar die
treppe oder mehr willen spricht da war
jetzt englisch was ich bin raus oben wie
gefällt er das haus ja ja ich mir war
ein bisschen ging ich mir eigentlich ein
bisschen zu groß
er will sich doch mal im haus um die
gefällt dir denn das haus ja ja ich mir
mal ein bisschen ging ich mir einige
mädchen zu groß die evelyn ist gerade
mal die treppe hochgelaufen und sagt wie
ist das alles ein bisschen zu groß
sie läuft jetzt gerade hier mit michael
rum geben das bild läuft jetzt wieder
nach links dreht wie eine kurve und
läuft zurück drehten das match hey leute
ich liebe diesen kanal und spaß last
allem aber den abo da sie läuft jetzt
die treppe runter benutzt dabei auch
elegant das geländer läuft runter bleibt
stehen und die tür trifft sie jetzt
gerade nicht durch die tür willen genau
da ist die tür jetzt dass sie draußen
angekommen
das hat eine nacht an sich er will
helfen evelin begutachtet erstmal die
hecke läuft jetzt durch den busch durch
wieder die treppe hoch verfehlt die tür
wieder ganz leicht und die will in
kamenz nichts anfangen sie läuft jetzt
wieder gegen die hecke und jetzt läuft
die lage der evelyn wurde gerade von
diesem
brecher der diese senioren die dort
zocken so ein bisschen durch das spiel
führt gesagt das ist dort auch ein auto
in der garage gibt das heißt wir schauen
jetzt mal was apple mit dem auto so
anstellt sie ist nun in der garage
angekommen steht vor dem auto und ich ja
gar nicht so einfach sie bewegt sich auf
das auto zu und steigt tatsächlich wie
ein gekonnter gta spieler in das auto
ein sehr gut ausgefallen benutzt die
andere taste fährt zurück fährt gekonnt
aus der einfahrt raus der audi ist schon
leicht demoliert dort vorne
sie fährt jetzt langsam aber vorsichtig
aus der einfahrt raus immer mehr weiter
könne willen passiert da noch was 2000
jahre später die evelin dreht die kamera
sieht das auto von der seite damals zu
dem ich heute gefahren
sie fährt an ganz langsam ganz
vorsichtig genauso wie man das macht das
hat mich gerade an meine erste
fahrstunde wo oder passiert etwas und
sie ist wieder in der garage
das war auch ein schöner sonntagsausflug
er will ihn fährt wieder ganz langsam
vorwärts jetzt tastet sie sich wieder in
die garage rein nach rechts an dafür
werden wir nach rechts fahren willst
dann muss man nach rechts drücken also
beim autofahren bei münchen wollte van
ist ja gleich
wir gehen gegen keine wir nicht fahren
jetzt mutig es denn soweit trainiert die
kriegen wir nicht hin er will ganz ruhig
noch im schnitt kinder wünscht gibt
genau ein stückchen genau jetzt
sie fährt wieder langsam aus der garage
raus das auto ist widerlich das fahrrad
evelyn und gemeine rückblenden
seine rückkehr
was ist deine rück bremsen jetzt kann
für jeden fall da die spuren mal ein
bisschen vorn schauen ob die evelin da
steht sie immer noch in dem dingens hier
ist die immer noch in der garage sie ist
hier immer noch in dem ding von lienz
ist sie jetzt könnt ihr sie schaffen
rauszufahren meine damen und herren
denn sie kann es schaffen meine damen
und herren sie kann es schaffen sie muss
einfach nur geradeaus fahren geradeaus
fahren müssen aber okay leute geben
denen ohne chance
ich mache ich mit rechen und jetzt
evelin das passend ausgepackt im
hintergrund und ob das was wird ob das
was wird
so kann sie schaffen sie fährt wieder
zurück bleiben stehen
ja ja ja ja nur wenig denn nun wieder
hin ja direkt wieder ein unfall gebaut
die heute hier mit rechte der völker
steht wird ja nicht eva ort ist kaputt
er will denn das wird schon seit zehn
minuten nichts wir spuren mal wieder ein
bisschen weiter durch ich hier steht sie
glaube ich an der kreuzung fahren sie
möchte um die ecke fahren würde ich aber
recht kommen nicht kriegt die kurve
heute nicht er will nun musst gas geben
um eine kurve zu kriegen so jetzt gibt
sie gas evelin falsche richtung nein er
will apple tablet
aber jens teuer machen und was nun fall
die villen ist jetzt ausgestiegen hat
eine handgranate in der hand meine damen
und herren das kann was werden wenn die
evelin der handgranaten hand hat er wird
in die granate mit einer handgranate die
läuft den weg lang und macht einen
schönen spaziergang genau nehmen wir mit
die läuft auf das auto zu meine damen
und herren und springt gegen das auto
jetzt ist dann auf dem auto es gibt mal
wieder so ein bisschen durch hier ist
sie dann irgendwann drei minuten später
das auto eingestiegen hier steht sie
wieder in irgend einer ampel bleibt
stehen weil es ist natürlich rot genauso
wie apple and are er will ihn gibt gas
meine damen und herren sie fährt sie
fern
und jetzt fährt sie weiter und jetzt
herzlich immer noch weiterfährt einer
kurve ganz knapp an dem auto vorbei
fährt weiter geradeaus gegen alba so
weißt du das ist wirklich was richtig
doofe fahrerflucht entwickeln dafür kann
man nicht anzeigen er würde es wieder
ausgestiegen und ich würde sagen wie es
gibt noch so ein bisschen durch ja
ja es ist vorbei er will in dieser zeit
aus dem krankenhaus raus gekommen läuft
jetzt ein bisschen lang natürlich wieder
im typischen evelin tempo hier läuft sie
gegen eine wand wenn man hier weiter
durchs gibt ist sie am gucken hier
weiter durch da ist ein typ interagiert
sie mit ihm ist evident ist auf
verfolgungsjagd sie ist schafft sie es
nein ich denn zu dem ich hier mein
digitales zu gehen er will ich mach mal
pause du bist nicht zudem nicht dass das
spiel ist wirklich schwierig und spart
sich das erst mal gespielt habe ich bin
überhaupt nicht klargekommen
also
die ersten zwei minuten nicht
das video geht jetzt schon 31 minuten
damit würde ich auch sagen beende ich
das heutige video meine damen und herren
ich fand's einfach so lustig habe diesen
channel entdeckt und ich hab mich total
verliebt das ist derzeit wenig die
einzige kann nach all dem ich in
deutschland verfolge bitte versteht dass
ich mich überhaupt nicht die senioren
die dort von lustig machen möchte ich
lache mehr mit ihnen weil ich das
einfach so interessant finde das zu
generationen aufeinander prallen also so
computerspieler und senioren das passt
eigentlich nicht so gut zusammen aber
das hier ist einfach mega interessant
und cool und witzig gestaltet der kanal
von denen es in der beschreibung
verlinkt wenn nicht auf ein anderes
video von denen mal reagieren soll dann
lasst mal einen fetten leichter und bei
50.000 reagiere ich auf das microsoft
video von bin hier findet ihr ins weil
die eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf könnte
ich meinen kanal abonnieren da oben
findet ihr auch meinen shop eingeblendet
und hier unten
ein anderes video und da das jetzt hier
verweis könnt ihr euch das da unten mal
anschauen